2014 was a year of personal risk and
professional reward for music legend
sting nothing of value is delivered from
lead singer to solo artist and this year
producer of a multi-million dollar show
on Broadway why sting is telling this
story on the Great White Way and what
the rock god thinks of today's biggest
music stars Plus what vanity or
Wooldridge has to do with his legacy all
in this edition of encores I look at you
stayin I mean you just had this amazing
career but then for you to go out again
and in many ways risk your reputation
one more time for this why nothing of
value is devoid of risk you know and I
enjoy that risk I mean what am i risking
my reputation I'm not risking my life
and I've always taken risks with the
artistic decisions I've made whether
it's the kind of music I play or the way
I present myself as an adult you know 63
year old man I'm not you know I'm not
pretending that I'm a kid 63 year old
man with a 21 year old body okay but a
14 year old mind but dumb I like risk I
like it's you know it's exciting for me
to do things that are difficult and then
succeed we hope which is what you've
done your whole life essentially yeah I
thought I have a good track record there
so hopefully this will work too maybe it
won't let's talk about the last ship how
difficult was it to put this thing
together I've chosen the most difficult
thing you could possibly do on the
roadway a musical and an original
musical that's you know written from the
bottom up most musicals are based on a
preexisting property you know a movie
successful movie or a fairy tale that
everyone knows and so introducing
something that's entirely new a story a
scenario that's completely fresh is the
most difficult thing you can do on
Broadway
and I knew that going in but it's so
satisfying to fight this battle this is
somewhat based on your own life history
and growing up around Newcastle so is
this musical also a little bit about a
statement or a commentary about how
we're living today the economy a labor
force I was born and raised in a
shipyard town in the north of England
literally in the shadow of a shipyard
giant ships would loom over my my street
my earliest memories of giant ships and
I did everything in my power to escape
working in that shipyard
my grandfather had worked there most of
the people who lived around me worked in
the shipyard it was toxic it was
dangerous it was noisy I didn't want to
end up there so I studied hard at school
I got a scholarship to a good education
I practiced music had this dream about
being a musician so it's ironic that I
would go back there in my creative life
to actually pay homage to the community
I came from the shipping industry was
destroyed really by economic forces
beyond the the power of the community
there's no way it could have survived
and yet the message of community being
the basis of economics is an important
one I don't think you can have economic
theories that that don't think of
communities being a major part of that
abstract theories don't work for me and
in that sense so the industry was
destroyed and the community went down
and this story is destroyed by what
destroyed my modernization it's a story
about you know you know it was cheaper
to build ships in Korea and Japan
because they were subsidized and our
government at the time refused to
subsidize the the shipbuilding industry
and so there was a very there was wasn't
exactly fair the playing field wasn't
level it had nothing to do with the
workmanship of these ships and was
they've been building ships for hundreds
of years and the best ships and so we
were very proud of that work
and then it went and so the thing that
identified us as a community was taken
from us and I think people in Detroit
would understand that idea you know when
you take an industry away from a
community how do they identify
themselves how does that community stay
in you know together and so my community
suffered in the same way so has it been
nail biting and nail biting it still is
I mean it's it's it's the voyage of a
ship you know we're trying to keep this
ship afloat every day is a new surprise
we you know we make three steps forward
two back and I announced I was going in
to the play which was a surprise to me I
didn't anticipate this but whatever it
takes to keep the ship afloat I will do
and I'm enjoying this struggle so what
triggered it was it looking looking at
the ticket sales looking at your figures
don't lie like all the the new musicals
on Broadway at the moment we're fighting
the same battle yeah and we're all happy
all have the same kind of figures
exactly luckily we have a secret weapon
which is me and I announced that and
then we took a stellar box office last
week so that that's clearly working so
what's stellar can you say can I say I
do I think we did 1.3 million in a week
which is more than enough to keep us
afloat is that like a 50% rise okay so
how come you to do that in the first
place it wasn't my intention
you know I'm very happy with the play as
it is without me in it but as I said
it's a difficult thing to get across to
the public that this is something they
will enjoy so I'm hoping to by going
into it for four weeks five weeks will
reach a tipping point because
word-of-mouth is very good but
word-of-mouth is slow you know it takes
it takes time or maybe two people have
to tell you to go and see a play before
you will decide so you know maybe 60,000
extra people will see it because I'm in
it and they're there word-of-mouth will
would take this to them in the
shangri-la to the promised land of
survival since we are a business network
we we like to dig into these numbers
right so how much have you actually put
of your own money into the line well you
know I put the last five years of my
life
time is money okay I haven't invested in
the show we have some very good
investors in fact we could have been we
could have a bankroll this thing on in
one day so many people wanted to do that
but you know Finance and me are not
particularly you know when uncomfortable
bedfellows you know I I'm an artist and
I let other people do that kind of thing
so you let you let other people raise
the money then or find the investors to
go did you care who was invested in this
oh actually I was very fortunate because
the two people who owned my record
company from from the 70s herb Albert
and Jerry moss were a nm records saw the
workshop and decided that they would
back me one more time I've known them
for a long time and they trust me
they're also artisan in their own right
and so so they understood the concept
they understood it wasn't easy to I have
a good relationship with our investors
and they're enjoying the struggle to
coming up I've made my money I'm well
off how today's musicians turn into
business type I'm impressed by
you